Vi vill att det bara ska hålla länge, man ska använda dem mycket.
Det kanske inte är det bästa för en omsättning, att du kan ha ett par kort som är 7-8 år gamla, men det är så vi vill att vi ska uppfattas att det är en clean och ren design.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni omsätter en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har ren dess bra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Ja, nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger det.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Simon Hallberg till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Och inför podden här när Simon pitchade för sin sambo, att han skulle vara med i podden, så sa hon, vad fan ska du vara med för?
Du är ju Sveriges tråkigaste människa.
Och med det introt och den cliffhangen så drar vi igång.
Stämmer det Simon?
Är du så jävla tråkig?
Tråkig?
Jag väl inte kanske, men jag kan ju vara lite gubbig.
Och jag brukar ju, både av vänner och sambor kanske kallas Sveriges yngsta gubbe.
Så det finns nog lite här under som kan vara lite kul ännu.
Tycker du om mandelbiskvir?
Är det en grej?
Hur blir man gubbe liksom?
Nej inte mandelbiskvir, sådana saker.
Jag är ju nog ganska barnslig när det gäller söt saker och godis.
Men jag gillar ju liksom hemmakvällar.
Jag är inte så spontan om jag vill planera saker.
Jag vill hela veta i förväg.
Ja men liksom när de säger, ja man kan vi komma till er ikväll?
Ja men nej, jag vet inte riktigt.
Där är jag nog mer.
Så jag kan nog vara lite gubbi och tåkig när det gäller sånt men nej.
Jag tror jag är en ganska rolig kille faktiskt.
Du har övertygat oss.
Är du sådant som när ni planerar semestern, så är det liksom kisspaus klockan 11-10 på Demprime för den har gåastoalett.
Sen pausar man på delluncheriet för den har lunchen för 94 kronor istället för 99.
Är du en sådan liksom?
Ja men jag gillar ju TripAdvisor.
De vet att vart jag ska käka, det kan jag säga.
På gott och ont så det kan ju bli lite åt det hållet.
Så kan det nog vara faktiskt tyvärr.
Vad är din titel?
Har du fått välja din titel själv i bolaget så som folket på mitt företag får göra?
Det skulle jag säga ja.
Vi har egentligen inga titlar.
Utan när jag började här så då hade jag någon jättelång titel.
Det var e-commerce, en digital content, bla bla bla, alltså ja, långt.
Men nu är det där e-commerce manager med en e-handelsansvarig.
Rådda våra e-handel.
Det är det jag gör primärt.
Är det ett sexigt jobb?
På pappret är det nog rätt sexigt.
Det låter väl, tycker alla man säger, när vi är managers nu på tiden.
Men, jo men det är väl ett sexigt jobb så att man kan styra sina timmar ganska gott tycker jag.
Och jag gillar det här liksom att vi har liksom inga arbetstider att tala om så.
Jo men såklart att man ska vara på jobbet mellan 8-17, så ska man ju liksom arbetstida.
Men vill man komma lite tidigare och gå tidigare kan man göra det där.
Börjar man sticka och klippa sig eller hämta barnen eller fotbollsträdning eller vad det är liksom, så länge man får jobbet gjort.
Det tycker jag kan klassas som ganska sexigt, såsatt att man är väldigt fri.
Jag gillar att det är definitionen av sexigt.
Nu vet jag inte och jag vet inte vart jag är på väg med den här meningen, men vad heter din sambo?
Sandra heter hon.
Vad är hon liksom sån?
Ja, du får börja kvart över åtta imorgon om du vill.
Fan vad, fan vad tendande.
Nej, jag sänder redan väl med.
Av alla jävla grejer att gå igång på.
Ja, flexibel arbetstid.
Det var inte det jag förväntade mig som svar liksom.
Vi kanske kommer tillbaka till den här gubbeten där.
Det är bara det peak life.
Ja, men det låter nog kanske sexigare än vad det är.
Det är mycket hårt jobb där faktiskt.
Om vi tar Celen Athletics som du jobbar för då, vad betyder Celen?
Ja, nej men vi vill faktiskt ut en liten film på det faktiskt i veckan.
I från början hette det ju faktiskt Clean Athletics, och det heter det fortfarande men alla säger Celen.
Det står ju faktiskt Celen.
Och nej men vi är särskilt träningskläder.
Och från början att gå in på det liksom lite, men hur det startade då var det ju att vi, eller vi, men två killar, William Berggren och Robin Rudholm, började träna Crossfit när det kom till Sverige för många år sedan.
Vi firar ju 11 år i år så det kanske är 13-14 år sedan.
Men vi blev helt fasta av den här träningsformen, det var ju liksom as coolt, du vet.
Kasta en boll hundra gånger upp för en vägg och sen göra hundra thruster och så låg man i en pöl efteråt och var hur trött som helst.
Jag tyckte ju de var as häftigt liksom och att de fastnade verkligen för den här träningsformen.
Och då började ju de lite om, ja men då skulle man ju ha grejer, du vet.
Grabbar överlag är ju nördiga när det gäller prylar och de två är väl ganska nördiga när det gäller prylar.
Hänga ut dem här.
Men, så, ja men då skulle man ju ha kläder.
Och det var ju grips och, du vet, allt sånt här.
Men just kläder på den tiden då, då fanns det inte jättemycket utan det var ju, Nike och Arm of Reebok var ju stora på den tiden och hade lärde av en bil med Crossfit.
Och de började beställa från USA var det ju då och ja men det passar lite dåligt då.
Sådana här saker då.
Pio på den tiden, han jobbade på 88-48 Altitude.
Robin drev en reklambid som han fortfarande driver som heter R3 Sweden.
Så det var en ganska bra match.
Pio designer Robin.
Jobbade mycket med att kunna ta fram logga och hemsidor.
De började skissa på det här och började...
Ja men den första prototypen var nog ett par shorts va.
Man gjorde det först till sig själv och sen berättade några kompisar på gymmet i boxen att de skulle ha lite kläder och sen växte det efterhand och så ba men vi startar en e-handel och så tog det upp dan och så man hade lite kontakter vid leverantörer och så.
Sen Pio hade den textilbakgrunden och så började det liksom smått.
Hemma i garaget liksom, eller i köket på kvällar och packade lite order.
De få som fanns och sen har det vuxit.
Men nu snöer iväg liksom.
En klin står ju egentligen då från Crosswitten.
Det är ju en övning på engelska i, ja men en frivänning på svenska.
Det är ju klin då.
Och athletics då är ju liksom kring träningskläder och träning.
Och sen gillar vi och de gillade det på den tiden också.
Och vi gillade fortfarande den här rena designen.
Så ofta när man har någonting snyggt så är det en klin design, det är nice, det är snyggt.
Och sen just kring träning och hälsa.
En klin och sund livsstil.
Allt från vad man äter och hur man tränar och den här biten.
Det är sådana saker vi vill stå och förmedla och det tror jag att vi gör idag.
Ja, men vi har breddat oss väldigt mycket från den lilla Crossfit nischen från början.
Nu är såklart inte alla lyssnare här insatta i träning på det sättet, men Crossfit var ju, när det kom så var det verkligen en ultra...
Alltså det var ju nästan i paritet med paddelboomen på något sätt.
Helt plötsligt öppnade det boxar och det öppnade en jävla massa boxar.
Det kom upp massa olika varumärken som skulle in i det här.
Det fanns väskor, det fanns kläder, det fanns kosttillskott, det fanns allt möjligt.
Crossfit har egentligen inte riktigt dött ut på samma sätt som paddel, utan det har bara snarare etablerats och så har det blivit lite mer standard.
Det finns ofta något Crossfit-gym i varje stad.
Men ni är ju inte bara Crossfit längre.
När gick ni ifrån att vara hård?
Crossfit-folk, då ska man veta om det är en sekt, eller det var i alla fall en sekt på den tiden.
Körde man Crossfit så körde man Crossfit och då var man verkligen inne i Crossfit.
Ofta hade man resten av träningsvärlden emot sig för att man gjorde många reps av varje övning.
Det blev lite, om vi tar alla fördomar från den tiden.
Verkligen, jag har varit där med.
Jag slängde av sig tröjan, bara Iber som vi såg på Ibet förr i tiden.
Det var det man tränade i.
Det var väldigt hardcore, helt klart.
Gick man då från Crossfit till andra grejer, eller hur gjorde man den?
För det är lite farligt att gå från en sån subnisch till att bli lite mer allmän.
Det blir lätt fel.
Var du med på den tiden och när kom du in?
Absolut.
Jag jobbade ju på 88-48 alltid tillsammans med PO.
Det var faktiskt han som fick in mig därför vi tränade Crossfit tillsammans på gymmet.
Sekt?
Sekt, precis.
Jag jobbade på lagret där på 88-48.
Sen efter några år ville PO satsa på clean till 100% och valde att satsa på det helhjärtat för han jobbade med båda sakerna.
Så då hängde jag med för att de behövde en kille som kunde hjälpa till på lagret eller så här på clean.
Så det var så det började.
Men från början, de första åren jag har jobbat här, det är nog mitt sjunde år nu, så första ett, två åren så var det CrossFit som gällde.
Men sen så blev det liksom, sen vi började testa lite nytt content och smög in lite mjukare värden och det funkade väldigt bra.
Och sen liksom egentligen så det var en ren tillfällighet.
Jag vet att vi var väldigt tidiga med det här UGC-annonseriet när det kom och då hade jag gått över och börjat jobba med E-handeln.
Liksom roddade Dan för vi hade en annan tjej som gjorde det från början.
Då slutade hon och så tog jag över det efter ungefär två år.
Då började vi testa väldigt mycket UGC och så gjorde vi en UGC-annons men det var en äldre kvinna och den liksom, jag ska inte säga för mycket men den var hemsk den annonsen och jag tycker fortfarande den är hemsk än idag om vi sålde så in i helvete föran.
Så det var en liten tillfällighet och då blev det såhär, oj, wow.
Det blev inte en ögonöppnare och vi lite också i samma veva så började vi själva liksom, från att ha varit så extremt mycket Crossfit, att träna annat själva.
Det var nog liksom när såhär, efter de här åren man hade gjort Crossfit så blev det såhär, ett bör man bli lite sliten i kroppen.
Och jag var ju extremt mycket och tränade ju 10-12 pass i veckan, liksom ett tag Crossfit och jag skulle bli Crossfit-proffs, tror jag, men det blev jag inte.
Men då började man liksom skaffa familjer, ett mindre träning, man började springa som alla medelåldersmän gör, och liksom sådana här saker och då det är ganska naturligt att vi kan ju ha våra grejer till de här sakerna också.
Det funkar det till paddel, det funkar till gymträning, det funkar till löpningar, men varför ska vi inte bredda oss liksom?
För att är det någonting vi alltid har haft så är det extremt bra produkter med hög kvalitet, med bra passformar och det är liksom, det är ju coren i hela bolaget att vi står för hög kvalitet som vi verkligen kan stå för liksom.
Och du hittar hela det här sortimentet på celenathletics.se.
Om du vill köpa nu så...
Eftersom ni börjar mot Crossfit, finns det någon skillnad på Crossfit-kläder och löpningskläder?
För när du säger att ni börjar det gå här, man kan lika gärna använda det på gymmet.
Är det egentligen någon skillnad eller är det bara branding?
Lite skillnad, det beror på hur nördig det ska vara med din träning.
Lite nördig då?
Lite nördig, men det är såklart att det finns olika material som passar till olika sorters träningar.
Har du något som är högpulsa, du svettar så extremt mycket då är det bra att ha material som är polyester eller mer mer mer mer mer som transporterar fukt.
Bommelskläder transporterar inte fukt på samma sätt.
Det blir, vet du, säker du själv när du har haft en bommelstisha och svettas som fan, då blir det tungt och blött liksom.
Det är lite olika vad som passar till olika träning.
Vad man själv gillar, jag är ju sådana här, fast jag tränar crossfit så vill jag gärna ha en t-shirt med bommelskänsla i för att jag tycker det är gott att bli svettig.
Vissa vill ju inte ha det så det är såklart att är du mer en nördig löpare skulle du kanske aldrig liksom, men nu har det ändrat i och för sig, nu har många bommel, men förr så var det ju såhär, du ska ha en polestetisha och det var ju ingen, en 50-60-årig man i dag är ju såhär, nu ska du träna, jag ska ha den här polestetisha, ganska var det här lite, det börjar lukta efter tre tvättar och det här, det är så det ska vara.
Så det finns ju, absolut att det finns material som passar bättre för olika sorters träning, det finns det.
Fick ni någonsin någon pushback från era gamla kunder när ni gick lite mer åt olika håll, var de såhär, vad fan, nu vill vi inte ha era grejer här på en sponsring typ.
Nej, det har vi inte fått sedan, vi har såklart fått kommentarer, eller vad tror jag, sociala medier eller så, de har skrivit såhär, jag handlar fortfarande hos er även fast ni har gått till att bli, bara göra tights till tjejer eller vad det nu kan vara.
Men det är ju också liksom, i kommunikationen så blir det såklart att man använder ju det som, vi har ju en ledstjärna som är såhär idag, att vi gör träningskläder för alla kroppar eller for everybody.
Det är ju liksom våran slogan idag.
Och vi bryr oss egentligen inte om vad du tränar för träningsform, utan vi vill ju att alla ska kunna ha våra kläder och vi försöker verkligen vara för den vanliga människan.
Så att, ja det kanske vi kommer in på sen mer.
Men, ja.
Nej men att, generellt sett nej.
Alltså de som gillar våra kläder, de köper det.
Sen har det såklart kommit andra märken som har tagit Crossfit-nischen idag.
Som är jätteduktiga.
Som, kan säga de gamla core-kunderna som vi har haft har berättat.
För lite så är vi lite men vi finns fortfarande för Crossfit-kunden, core-kunden.
Sen är vi, alltså vi har ju olika kollektioner idag.
Där vi har en kollektion som är riktad mer mot, nu får man inte säga Crossfit utanför det, funktionell träning.
Crossfit är ett brand men som är riktad mot det då.
Vi hade när, nu är detta också många år sen, detta är ju under den Crossfit-hypen eller vad man ska säga då, när det verkligen växer, då ryktades det ju på Fibo som är en stor träningsmässa då, att det gick runt advokater från Crossfit, någon slags, de som hade liksom ägandeskapet över det, och sa till folk som hade ordet Crossfit på sina hemsidor att de fick böter då, så att...
Ja, jag tror jag har fått tre eller fyra sådana mejl genom åren där vi...
Ja, vi måste ta bort det från hemsidan, för att annars blir det böter, och för att vi har använt ordet Crossfit på hemsidan.
Nu tror jag faktiskt inte att det finns ett enda ord idag, men vi ligger fortfarande etta på Crossfit-kläder när man googlade, så att det måste vara sen om åren har vi gjort.
Ja, det var då alla bytte till Xfit.
Precis.
Funktionell fitness heter väl det, de har skapat ett förbund för det.
Crossfit har fått en liten turn senast åren, så man kanske inte vill förknippa sig för mycket med det.
Nej, det har gått hur mycket där.
Det blir ett eget avsnitt.
Det blir ett eget avsnitt, vi behöver inte prata om det.
Om vi tar er, du sa att ni var ganska tidiga med UGC-material och liknande.
Min fördom är ju att det är träningskläder ganska mycket.
Det kommer upp ett brand och så syns det väldigt mycket och så får man ut det till väldigt mycket influencers och så är det det som syns ett år eller två och sen så kommer nästa sådan omgång.
Ni har ändå hållit på ett tag nu liksom, alltså tio plus år.
Hur överlever man?
Ni är inte de första som ska in i träningsbranschen och göra kläder och ni är ju inte, vad ska man säga, ni är ju inte största.
Det finns ju ett antal riktiga jättar att slås mot.
Hur liksom sticker man ut i den världen?
Jag menar absolut, det finns ju otroligt många tränningsklädersmärken idag och jag tror inte att det är något märke som är dåligt, utan alla, man vill göra bra produkter som folk gillar, för det är ju den bästa marknadsföringen, det är ju att den kunde handla någonting och de får en positiv upplevelse, det var bra kläder och hela den här biten.
Det är mycket bättre än att en influencer handlar där för att det här är bra.
Men det har ju varit tufft att vi har hållit på i tio, elva år här nu, det är ju för senaste tre, fyra åren egentligen som det liksom har hänt saker.
Och det är ju nu vi har gått ifrån det här råa, tuffa, men även att vi försöker vara mycket mer personliga och göra något annorlunda mot andra.
Vi har provat lite influencers, men det har inte funkat för oss.
Än så länge har det inget vi satsar på av flera olika anlingar.
Jag tycker att det är svårt att mäta och allt sånt här.
Vi är väldigt tunga på egen annonsering, framförallt med Jetta då, med Instagram och Facebook.
Så där lägger vi mycket av vår marknadsföringsbudget.
Där försöker vi vara liksom, om man har fått upp vår reklam så har man nog sett alla som jobbar med oss i reklamen.
Vi försöker visa upp oss själva, väldigt liksom native.
Det kan vara från lagret, det kan vara från kontoret och så här.
Men sen har vi det även med klassiskt UGC, som vi har utvecklat genom åren, det har hänt otroligt mycket med det.
Så att där tror jag att vi skiljer oss mot de andra märkena som, ja men vi försöker vara mer normala, uppfattas mer normala för att jag tror att folk gillar det.
Jag hoppas det.
Det känns såna i alla fall.
Kan du tycka att det är lite märkligt?
Alltså vi använder oss också av den sortens, jag försöker också ha någon sorts normal approach till livet och när man syns och sånt där.
Och folk gillar ju det.
Men jag kan också tycka att det är lite halvfascinerande att folk såhär, hej jag tänkte köpa en skivstång och jag tänkte köpa den hos er för du verkar normal.
Ja, det spelar ingen roll för skivstången.
Det där är ett PSI-värde och en hårdhet.
Skit i fall, ja det är väl inte det man köper grejer på.
Och det är samma sak inom kläder.
Det är jättemånga företag som har den här strategin nu, att det är klart att man ska visa upp sig själv.
Men vad spelar det för roll egentligen?
Varför slår det så jävla hårt?
Nej, det är en väldigt bra fråga.
Jag tror ju personligen såhär att, ja men sen sociala medier och allt sådant som har exploderat, så är det såhär att folk gillar att följa folk.
De följer ju inte varumärken egentligen, de följer ju människor.
Det är därför som när influencermarketing kom, då var det ju, det slog ju så hårt för att folk gillar att följa folk.
Inte att de...
Nu vet inte jag, men jag följer ju inga varumärken för att jag tycker att det är...
Ja men det är roligt att kolla på deras reels eller stories för det är varumärken, utan jag följer ju det för arbetsmässigt för att jag ska ha koll på vad våra konkurrenter och andra gör, men det är ju det man följer folk som man gillar, alltså det kan vara allt från gräsmattefolk när man är gubbig som jag till mat och allt sånt här.
Du följer ju människor och så får du en känsla att om den här människan verkar rolig, så är det trevligt vad det nu kan vara.
Det är därför jag tror att sånt kanske funkar bättre i dagens samhälle, för att du är lite, men du är förbi det här kanske, att det är ouppnårbara, om du förstår vad jag menar, det är den här livsstilen som kanske många människor, eller många människa, jag tror inte att alla strävar efter den, utan det har nog bara blivit någon sån här att alla vill hit och vara så som en influencer är kanske, men jag tror att folk, ja men de gillar att följa folk och är man en vanlig människa så är det nog ganska trevligt att följa vanliga människor.
Du nämner att det är lite det ni jobbar med marknadsföringsmässigt, men finns det några detaljer i era produkter eller finns det något sätt i era arbetssätt som man kan se att det här är Clean eller CLN, hur vet man att det här är era grejer, vad är det folk verkligen uppskattar?
Men det var som jag sa, vi är ju inte alls lika trendiga som vissa konkurrenter är.
Vi är oftast ett-två år bakom på bollen.
För några år sen kom de här flat tights, alltså utsvängda tights.
Det är ju jättestort idag och tjejer har ju det.
Det är nog inte jättemånga som har det tränat, man har det till vardags.
När man ska hämta barnen eller gå och handla.
De är ju lika sköna som ett par träningstights, men de ser ändå lite casual och nice ut.
Konkurrenterna gjorde ju det här ett-två år förra, och sen hakar vi på det.
Men trenden har blivit enorm.
Vi försöker ju vara tidläsa i vår design.
Det har ju lite med vårt hållbarhetsarbete att göra.
Att vi ska ha en tidlös design, vi vill att våra kläder ska hålla länge, och man ska använda dem mycket.
Det kanske inte är det bästa för en omsättning, att du kan ha ett par...
Vi har flera kompisar och även jag som har skjort som är 7-8 år gamla.
Det kanske inte är det bästa såsätt, men det är så vi vill att vi ska uppfattas, att en clean och ren design, en stillren design överlag, där tror jag att det är det folk känner.
Annars är vi inte så här att Stronger, de har sitt strif på benen som man känner igen, men jag skulle inte säga att det är jättemånga som har en så signi att man bara, det här är det här plagget, eller det här varumärket idag, utan alla är ju ganska så.
Det är ju lite så skandinavisk design du vet, avskalat.
Det vi kanske har strukturit förr genom åren, det var ju framförallt killar, alltså lite tuffa print på t-shirtar och sånt.
Det har vi gått ifrån under några år, men det börjar komma tillbaka igen, för nu är det ju lite trendigt.
Det började komma för ett, två år sen innan det kom tillbaka, och nu börjar vi göra det ett, två år efter igen.
Ni kör lite sådana här hållbarhetsgrejer, generaliserar jag lite, men ni har lite olika grejer som ni jobbar med.
Jag är alltid fascinerad när folk uttalat är hållbarhetsbolag.
Då undrar jag alltid vart man drar skiljelinjerna.
Jag tycker det är spännande, när blir det för dyrt?
Alltså hur nördig får man bli och hur långt får man dra det innan kunderna bara skiter i det?
Och liksom det inte blir bra längre för att man får inte ut någonting.
Det är en väldigt bra fråga och jag tror att vi var ju tidiga på bollen med att använda återvunna material och allting vi gör idag ska vara återvunna materialer, ekologiskt, de här bommer till exempel.
Och det är en uttala policy som vi har och det kommer ju regler och allt sånt här.
Jag är inte superinsatt i det, så man ska vara ärlig och ta med någon annan här.
Men jag tror ju generellt så här idag, förr var det ju en usp, alltså ett särskilt argument att vi jobbar med återvunna material och så vidare, man håller bara ett arbete idag, så är det ingen usp längre, utan det är vardag.
Alltså, alla gör det.
Så det är ingenting kanske du vinner på.
Däremot så tror jag som jag sa tidigare att, ska man krast säga så här om du jobbar med kläder, kläder generellt, det är inte bra för miljön.
Punkt slut.
All konfektion är ju, alltså vi lever i ett konfektionssamhälle, det är inte bra för miljön.
Så är det ju.
Och därför försöker vi jobba med hållbarhet i kvalitet på våra kläder, att man ska kunna använda dem ofta och länge, istället för att alltid behöva köpa nytt.
Det ser vi som mer hållbart än att man jobbar med vad det nu kan vara för material som är mer hållbart än detta, än detta.
Utan istället att minska, inte minska, för vi lever på att sälja, så klart vi vill sälja, men jag tror att handlar du en plagg oavsett om det är från oss eller från någon annan och du gillar det, det håller länge det är bra, men då kommer du att handla det igen.
Så jag tror att det är så man i framtiden ska tänka på hållbarhet.
Det är därför liksom så här, jag själv kan ju inte fatta, jag har såklart handlat från Tjene eller Teme, Teme har jag aldrig handlat med, jag handlade på toffler på Tjene för något år sedan, men visst det är billigt, men det är också skit.
Alltså du, och så är du ju alltid här i världen, du får ju vad du betalar för oftast, generellt.
Så det lönar sig oftast att köpa kvalitet kontra att det beror på vad det ska vara.
Men att gå på det billigare alternativet.
Så det är hållbarhet för oss numera.
Sen såklart att man använder det ur ett försäljningskynpunkt för något år sedan, och det var jättemånga som gjorde det.
De klimatkompenserade det här och det där, men summa summarum, säljer du träningskläder, det kanske inte är det bästa för miljön.
Men nu gör vi det och det är det vi lever på.
Vi vill ju också att folk ska bli inspirerade att träna för att må bättre och hjälpa folk i deras liv med sin träning och kan våra kläder underlätta det, så det är fantastiskt.
Och kan de använda kläderna ofta mycket så är ju det kan de.
Du ska snart få några e-handelsfrågor också.
Jag vet att du bara får en massa frågor som berör allt annat.
Men en grej som jag tycker är att alla, det känns som att träningskläder allt mer går mot vanliga kläder.
Alltså förr var träningskläder träningskläder, och djupaskor var djupaskor.
Och nu är träningskläder vanliga kläder.
Eller det ska vara nån sorts mitt emellan.
Ni säljer ju saker som typ flis, tröjor och liknande.
När klassas det inte som träningskläder längre?
Nej det har vi själva pratat om.
Ja men många konkurrenter till oss idag, de säljer lite allt möjligt.
Det beror på hur stor man är, vi är fortfarande ett litet bolag.
Så vi kan ju inte bredda våra kollektioner med mycket sådant här för att binda lagar och sånt här.
Så vi försöker ju hålla det väldigt smalt.
Vi gör ju till exempel bara 20-30% nytt varje år.
Sen är resten återkommande.
Produkter kanske kommer med någon ny säsongsfärg.
Men jag tror att det är hela hur modet har gått.
I Sverige framförallt då, eftersom vi säljer primär till Sverige idag, så är det ju väldigt såhär, en hoody, en nice hoody, eller som jag sa, de här flertightsen, det kan ju klassas som träningskläder på något sätt, men det funkar ju lika bra till vardags.
Och jag tror att det är modet generellt, för på något sätt tycker vi i alla fall att om en, om en som är en hoody eller på mysbyxor, det passar ju ändå till träning, för vissa tränar ju i det, men det är också nice att ha till och från träningen.
Eller liksom efter träningspasset när du softar i soffan, eller sådana här saker, så att vissa saker kan du ändå hålla ihop till träning.
Och än så länge har inte vi liksom gått utanför det, men det kanske kommer, men när man börjar liksom göra, för vår egen del så försöker vi hålla oss inom träningsmänster så mycket som det går, men det är ju ändå så här, har vi till exempel ett par flertights, tajt är ju träningstajt, men då är det ju nice att ha en snygg flis.
Och i vårat fall så har vi en kund idag som inte, vi har inte den här träningskunden längre, utan vi har ju en kund som är mer, lite äldre kanske, alltså medelålders, som liksom vill känna sig sportig då.
Kanske inte tränar fem dagar i veckan, man kanske promenerar två dagar i veckan, men då kan träningskläderna göra att man känner sig lite mer tränig eller sportig eller lite mer hälsosam.
Då funkar det perfekt med en flis när du ska gå ut på en kvällsformulad till exempel.
Ja, men jag fattar det här, jag kan se vilka som, det är som att man går ut med hunden den här flisträdan till exempel.
Den är väldigt snygg, och det har ju med modet att göra idag.
En fleece idag har ju ett modeplagg, eller en pailjacka eller vad man så kallar det då.
En fleecejacka tycker jag kan låta lite såhär, det låter ju lite, pail är ju en modernare ord av fleece, man har gjort det lite sexigare helt enkelt, för att det ska låta sexigare.
Så Daniela, det plagget som är så långt ifrån träning som vi har egentligen, men annars så tycker jag att vi håller ihop det ganska bra.
Sen är det ju så här produktbräddningar men vi har ju rätt mycket mjukhetskläder och sånt, och det har ju gjort att det bland annat är en anledning varför vi ökar så mycket förra året, för att vi lanserade det förra året.
Så det blir en ny produktkategori och jag vet att du ska lyssna på din podd, du har ju pratat om det flera gånger, ska vi bredda vår, då blir det särskilt kosttidskott eller vad det nu kan vara, så klart man kan genomgå in i en ny kategori så kan du ju öka din omsättning.
Så att, men man får nog göra det på ett smart sätt, eller vi försöker göra det på ett smart sätt i alla fall.
Ja men vi behöver våld i ansvaret, vi gör träningskläder för vanliga människor och vi är vanliga människor så att det är ju våra egna pengar vi har att spela med liksom.
Exakt, ni gjorde ju en ganska rejäl tillväxt förra året, ni gick upp från typ 17 miljoner till typ 29 miljoner och klonkade ut lite vinst, som var ganska trevlig också.
Vad, vad ska man säga, märks det?
Du vet, eller är det bara att här är mer lager nu eller kunde ni helt plötsligt börja satsa på fan vi kan också ha ett riktigt mailsystem nu eller ska vi bygga ut hemsidan lite?
Det här har vi kört i WordPress i tolv år.
Nu biter vi faktiskt plattformar i höst, så det är ju en trygghet och det har vi tänkt göra länge.
Är det du som har drivit på detta?
Ja, eller vi är nog allihopa som känner det.
Men den vinsten vi gjorde förra året, det finns hål att stoppa i om vi säger så.
Det kan man ju bara kolla så att det inte är så att vi har gått med några, det har varit runt plus minus noll, lite minus här och där, lite plus här så att det finns hål att stoppa de pengarna i.
Så att, och det är ju en trygghet såklart att att veta då att man ligger på en viss nivå, att man kanske kan göra vissa saker för att utveckla bolaget liksom.
Det kan ju vara sjukt snabbt åt andra hållet också.
Våren var nog tuff för många, den var lite tuff för oss också liksom, men man tog kanske lite, vi ska nog testa lite med Influencer Marketing igen, så började man och så bara, nej, paus, stopp, hambroms, snabbt som tusan.
Så det är lätt att när det går bra, att då ska man ju lägga de här tängarna, du fattar precis vad jag menar, någonstans för att kunna växa ännu mer.
Så att jag tappar nästan bort mig vart vi var här.
Om det märks i företaget att ni har tjänat några kronor?
Jo, det märks men det är nog ett lugn skulle jag säga istället.
Att man kanske har kommit på en nivå och har en viss trygghet.
Men tror jag så här e-handeln i sig är ju aldrig lugn, för det går ju så snabbt.
Alltså vi säljer ju retail också och där är det ju grundordning och sådant där.
Det ger ju en trygghet kanske för e-handeln däremot.
För för att vara så extremt beroende av vår e-handel att han skulle producera varenda dag.
Det är man ju inte längre på samma sätt.
Hur stor är det andra delen som inte är e-handel?
Förra året var det ungefär 60-40 fördel i e-handeln.
Oj, aha.
Så innan det hade varit 70-30 ungefär.
Men vi har vuxit med en kund ganska mycket.
Och det gjorde det bra.
Men det är ändå inte där varumärket utvecklas så mycket, men det ger en trygghet för att kunna växa varumärket såklart.
Ja.
Vad är det, som du säger, vi har varit i bolaget ett tag och gjort lite annat möjligt.
Vad är det du går igång på?
Vad är dina områden som ingen får pilla på?
Nej men det har vi innan gjort.
Inte nästan, men jag har gjort allt senaste åren.
Jobbat med hemsidan, våra Facebook-annonser, våra Google-annonser, nyhetsbrev, skapat produkter, kontakt med ambassadörer.
Hela den har jag gjort själv nästan till.
Sen har vi lite konsulter på vissa saker och stöttning här, men vi är ju inte så många.
Nu har vi anställt en tjej här i våras då.
När man har lite trygghet så kan man kanske göra det.
Som jag jobbar mycket med, content bland annat.
Men vilka områden, när hon kom in och sa honom, jag kan jobba med det här, vilka områden var det du sa, nej, det där rör du fan inte, det är mina områden.
Vad är det roligaste?
Jag tycker det är roligaste att sälja.
Vad menar du med att sälja, är det att snacka med kund eller snacka med andra leverantörer?
Nej, nej, i handel.
Jag tycker framförallt att ads är jäkligt roligt.
Meta-annonser, det går över i gång.
Jag tycker det är fantastiskt kul.
Men jag sköter fortfarande att vara en kundkänns mig, så var jag kunde där.
Men skit i kunderna ett litet tag.
Vi bara hoppar om.
Om vi går in på meta-adser, det finns ju, jag vet att alla använder meta-adser och det går ju fortfarande bra.
Hur kan det fortfarande gå bra?
Vem, det är ju ingen som, alla säger att de inte använder Facebook längre och det är ingen som postar på Facebook utan allting är ju nu för tiden bara företagsgenererat content typ, jag överdriver lite, men hur kan det funka och vad är det som funkar?
Ja, det beror nog på vilken målgrupp man har.
Vi har ju fortfarande en målgrupp som kanske är, våra målgrupper ligger någonstans 30-60.
Liksom huvudmålgruppen är ju såklart bred men det tror jag fortfarande man går in på Facebook lite per automatik, jag gör min dagligära är det.
På något sätt är det ju så här, det är ju olika människor som handlar på en Facebook-annons.
Vissa människor, så vill du bara att de ska ha dig i bakhuvudet hela tiden.
När det väl är dags.
Om man generaliserar grovt, killar, handlar det inte jättemycket impulsivt på en Facebook-annons, i alla fall när det gäller träningskläder.
De passar på när det är ett erbjudande.
Nu handlar jag mina två pausår så tre tisdagar här, så kör vi liksom.
Medan en tjej är mer, kanske generaliserar jag igen, mer impulsiv liksom.
Ja, men de här tajten såg härliga ut och de var bra att passa på.
Ja, men du fattar, de ska inte kassa ner och allt sånt här.
Och de kan vara mer impulsiva då.
Men jag tror i dag, i dagens samhälle så, man vet att det kommer Facebook-annonser eller Instagram-annonser om du inte har stängt av det och helt och hållet.
Nej, du kan ju inte stänga av det.
Jo, du kan nog köpa det nu tror jag.
Stänga av det, betala det men det tror jag inte är många människor gör.
Det finns ju ingen som gör det.
Nej, men jag tror ju att det handlar om mycket, både liksom då att ha bra material såklart, så att knöda ner oss hur mycket som helst.
Att få folk att titta på dina filmer och fastna i dem, det gör ju mycket.
Sen behöver de inte handla på den.
Det är inte det viktigaste, utan att de tittar och konsumerar vårt innehåll, det är det som är absolut viktigast.
Det är ju det här fallet då vi gör mycket filmer när vi står själva och pratar om produkter, man utbildar kunderna och såna här saker.
Bland har vi så här, passa på, filmer ska gå lite snabbt och så får de att handla snabbt om det är ett erbjudande.
Generellt så tror jag att det handlar om att få folk att titta och sen träffpunkter.
Att när det är väl kunden är redo, då ska vi vara top of mind på den kunden.
Om det är så att jag behöver en ny flysäckare, eller mjukisbyxor är en sådan sak.
Det säljer vi sjukt mycket av på hösten, eller vintertights på höst och vinter.
Du köper det när du behöver det, och då ska vi vara top of mind när kunden kommer på att jag behöver det här.
Eller att vi måste påminna dem att du behöver det här.
Eller att de har ett problem som vi ska lösa.
Det är mer nykundsrekrytering att hitta kundernas problem, vad det nu kan vara.
Mina tights hakar alltid ner eller jag saknar ficka på tightsen.
Då ska vi hitta det problemet på den här målgruppen och hitta de kunderna som har just det här problemet som vi har i den här filmen.
Hoppningsvis kan vi lösa deras problem och de handlas ändå.
Hur förmedlar man, nu ber jag om ursäkt till alla som lyssnar för nu tänker jag prata om mjukisbyxor i tre minuter, men jag är en mjukbyxsekund, jag är en sån som köper mjukbyxor på hösten och sen går jag liksom med dem i ett halvår.
Det är bara, alltså nonstop, det är så jag jobbar.
Ett problem med mjukisbyxor är att de måste sitta jävligt gött, annars är de helt meningslösa.
Jag tycker att det är lite läskigt att köpa mjukisbyxor på e-handeln för att man inte får testa dem, för det kan verkligen kännas annorlunda.
Och sådana här grejer som, ett par hård kan jag tycka typ sitter alltid okej.
Så tycker jag.
Det är bara för att kille.
Jaha, så kanske det är.
Men mjukisbyxor, hur förmedlar man, det är liksom ett plagg som ska vara gött, hur förmedlar man det i en annons?
Ja men det är också olika produkter som säljer på olika plattformar.
Mjukisbyxor är ingen metaprodukt.
För metaprodukt är det mer så att du vill visa upp kanske vad för problem den här produkten kan lösa eller vad de har för uspar, tajt med fickor eller tajt med reflexor och sådana saker.
Medan ett par mjukisbyxor är mer en Google-produkt.
Våra mest sålda mjukisbyxor är ju gråa mjukisbyxor till här.
Det är ju en Google-produkt, den presterar alltid bra på Google och då gäller det ju att synas när folk googlar det, eller grabbarna googlar det här.
Sen kan det ju vara så att man får se helheten då, om man ska vara lite nödig, att det kanske var att ja men du behöver dina mjukisbyxor.
Du gick in och googlade och så var du lite osäker såhär.
Fan, kommer de här passa mig?
Jag gillar ju tajtpassform, jag gillar löspassform eller vad det nu kan vara då så kollar du på dem här.
Och sen när du kommer hem på kvällen sen efter du har, eller dagen efter så får du upp en annons i ditt flöde där vi pratar om de här mjukisbyxorna på Instagram.
Där vi försöker utbilda dig och visar att de har de här fickorna, de här har drarkedjor och de här har inte det.
Då kanske du, alltså vi försöker ju tänka, det var faktiskt väldigt roligt, det var en kompis till oss som sa häromdagen så här, han är en gammal klutahandlare säger vi, han har sålt kläder i många år.
Jag tycker era annonser är så bra för det är ju som, det är så man snackar i en butik.
Det tror jag menar.
Så det är lite det vi vill åt med annonseringen också.
För då blir det just med träffpunkterna, du kanske kom in genom Google första gången, var ändå lite osäkert, men sen så förhoppningsvis har algoritmen gjort rätt och du får upp den här annonsen med mjukisbyxorna efter.
Det vi kanske kan utbilda dig.
Okej, ja men det var det som poff, nu fick vi honom och så ger du ditt köp då.
Och förhoppningsvis så är du ju nöjd med det köpet och kommer tillbaka liksom.
Är det inte jävligt störigt att hålla på och om ni breddar sortiment och så breddar ni sortiment och så har ni både herre och dam.
Jag fattar att för de allra flesta så är 28 miljoner as mycket pengar att sälja kläder för, men jämfört med stora jättar så är det ju inte så mycket pengar, men det är väldigt många olika produkter och SKU, så det är olika, vad ska man säga, det är olika inkörsportar som du säger med en grå mjukisbyxor på Google och det är andra grejer som ska säljas snabbt och trenda.
Är det inte bara lite krångligt att ha det så brett?
Hade det inte bara varit skönare att hålla det tajt och enkelt?
Jo, det har varit mycket att gå över att sälja gymutrustning.
Nej, det kan man ju ofta tänka.
Fan vad gott det hade varit att sälja något som är tidlöst.
Tränningskläder kan ju vara tidlöst, vi försöker tänka tidlöst, men att ha en produkt som inte är säsongs...
Vi har ju några produkter som är året runt produkter.
Våra bästsäljande tajt eller Horsstekille till exempel, de funkar ju året runt, oavsett om det är kallt eller varmt.
Det är där vi lägger mycket pengar, det är våra hero-produkter, det är där vi trycker marknadsföring så mycket som möjligt.
Sen har vi ju vissa säsongsprodukter, som man om en bikershorts eller cykelbyxor till sig säljer så in i helvete under några månader.
Det är inte en jävel som köper sådana i december, men de köper vintertajt istället i december.
Vissa produkter blir ju säsongsbetonade.
Men ja, det hade varit enklare att kanske sälja någonting som är mer tidlöst och inte liksom säsongsbetonat.
Sen är det utmanande att sälja både dam och herr.
Det kan jag hålla med om.
Men varför väljer man till exempel att bredda snart men snarare än att bara vi ska sälja gråa mjukisar i hela världen?
Eller vad menar du nu?
Varför säljer ni inte bara gråa mjukbyxor på global nivå och bara skiter i allt annat?
Är det för att det inte är kul eller?
Ja, det är faktiskt en jävligt bra fråga.
Okej, här ska jag ta det an på nästa styrelse med såhär så får vi diskutera det här.
Ja, men det är såklart att, för något sätt så blir det ju, som jag sa, man har ju, alltså, vi brukar tänka såhär är det.
20% av vår kollektion står för 80% av vår omsättning.
Så är det och så är det nog för många.
Därför försöker vi, som jag sa innan, att vi försöker inte göra så mycket, vi försöker hålla det ganska tajt.
Även om det kan upplevas ganska mycket, så försöker vi hålla det tajt så mycket det bara går.
Och göra liksom, men det som funkar, det är det vi ska sälja mer av och mycket.
Sen är det vissa, vi har haft en diskussion om, till exempel, vindjacka, vi har en vindjacka på handsidan, den har funnits där i fem månader men vi har inte gjort någon ny vindjacka.
Men den är ju bara en liten kantboll, det är inte där vi växer.
Vi växer med våra träningstights, till exempel.
Det är ju skalbart, dammprodukten går att skala, vindjackan går kanske inte att skala på samma nivå.
Jag är lite nyfiken på, för ni känns ju, och jag kan ju ingenting om er, men ni känns ju som ett, typ tre bolare som driver bolag här, med risk för att missuppfatta och så kommer det in några nya och sånt där.
Men liksom, hur bibehåller man lite friktion, så att man inte blir hemma blind och bara bekväm i det där, utan vi ska fortsätta göra det här bra och ifrågasätta varandras tankar och sånt där.
Och du får inte säga, har vi högt i tak?
För att det är ett för enkelt svar.
Jag tror att det handlar om individer och att man har rätt individer i bolaget i så fall, att man vill framåt.
Det är såklart, och det diskuterar vi jättemycket, och vi har inte beslutat helt vart man ska heller.
Det är såklart att man vill växa.
Jag tror att som personligen, jag är väldigt tävlingsinriktad, jag vill alltid bli bättre och har alltid velat.
Alltså ända från jag var liten när man spelade handboll, sen när man skadade sig, sen blev det crossfit.
Man vill bli bättre på saker, man gillar att utvecklas.
Så jag tror det är viktigt att ha personer, några personer i alla fall som vill bli bättre.
Sen behöver man också personer som bara vill gå till jobbet och göra sitt jobb.
Så det är nog att hitta en sådan mix i ett bolag tror jag, om man ska ta det vidare.
Om det var svar på din fråga.
När jag inte fick säga att vi var högt i tak.
Vem sitter med idéer och är såhär, ska vi inte testa detta?
Har ni funderat på detta?
Jag tror att vi är nog ganska dåliga på att reflektera eftersom vi är ganska få.
Vi har gått sjukt snabbt sista åren.
Så vi är ganska dåliga på att reflektera.
Långt fram, vi lever extremt mycket här och nu.
Eller jag lever i alla fall väldigt mycket här och nu.
Inte jättelånga men jag vet att det kommer en black week här om några månader.
Jag har ju bakom mig att jag måste börja förbereda det nu.
Ska ni byta plattform innan det eller efter?
Ja innan det.
Nervöst är du för det då?
Ja, jag har mailade.
Jo nej men jag kan bara...
Jag ångrar mig lite nu men det ska gå bra.
Det kommer gå bra.
Eller så går det åt helvete, men då går det åt helvete.
Men nej det kommer gå bra, jag är rätt säker på.
Men efterhand kanske man skulle ha gjort det i februari istället.
Men nu gjorde vi det.
Generellt sett så är vi ganska dåliga tror jag på att planera långt fram.
Det är först nu som vi i år har startat en riktig styrelse, som liksom har möten, riktiga styrelsmöten, och ser på de lite stora punkterna framåt.
Så det har vi precis börjat med.
Efter det fanns förr vet jag, men sen har det liksom kommit av sig lite och nu när vi har ändå blivit, när det börjar bli lite mer på riktigt om vi ska säga så, så där kanske vi jobbar mer i de stora frågorna, dagarna här är annars ganska fullspäckade.
Vi är i eget lagar, vi packar våra egna ordrar.
Vi är visst inne i lite bemanning men är det så att efter en helhet vi har 600 ordrar, då står vi nere på lagret och packar de ordrarna.
För kunder ska avsikta sina saker då, efter punkt slut.
Sen kommer vi ju till en nivå nu, när det börjar bli så stort, så kanske det inte hinner helt och hållet men alltså, så att, nej men dagarna här är annars ganska, de är explosiva om man säger så, det går fort.
Så att långt fram i tanken är vi inte alltid.
Och det är någonting som vi ser som, hela det här året, med plattform att byta, lite nya anställningar och sånt där, det blir väldigt mycket struktur för att senare kunna liksom, skala det ännu mer och förhoppningsvis.
Så får man se vart det leder.
Men ja.
Fan, jag har försökt ställa sista frågan till det här typ, fyra gånger nu men varje gång du har svarat så kommer jag på en ny fråga som jag tycker är spännande och nu, nu nämner du, jag är ju väldigt fascinerad av styrelser, vi har ju ingen styrelse och, och, och jag, ja, det känns verkligen som att jag har saknat någonting eller missat någonting i detta, så jag försöker alltid liksom fatta och, nu säger du att ni har startat en styrelse, är det ni som sitter i styrelsen eller har ni några externa eller är det?
Vi har en extern, har vi.
Och varför vi startade och så har vi fått med, ja det är ju inga hemligheter för alla bolag, och sen känner vi Anton Petersson heter han, de som jobbar med han vet säkert var man är, och en otroligt kompetent kille och duktig, och det är ju också för att få lite nya ögon på det som du sa, alltså så här, tankar du det, vi lever ju i våra lilla bubblar, det är lite skyddlapp här på, vi såhär gör vi, så bara kör man.
Där kan det ju bli lite mer att vi kanske börjar tänka utanför, varför gör ni såhär, varför gör ni såhär, varför gör ni inte så, ställa frågor och såhär gör andra bolag, och blablabla.
Men just för att kanske kunna väckla upp lite och faktiskt börja tänka till lite mer.
Än så länge är det faktiskt jättebra tycker jag.
Han har skött sig.
Ja, vad gott.
Då vet ni vem ni ska höra av er till.
Simon, stort tack för att du var med i podden, och var kul att få lära sig lite om träningskläder.
Vi ska inte in i den branschen, jag kommer aldrig bli din konkurrent.
Det låter knepigt.
Helt klart, vi var faktiskt kort väg in i gymmutrustningsvärlden för något år sedan.
Vi har ett skottröja nere på lagret med vår egen logga.
Helvet också.
Längre så kom vi inte.
Vad var det mer?
Var det det enda terorikten ni tog fram eller?
Ja, det var en polare som kan svetsa, så gjorde vi ett skottröja med vår logga i och lite sånt här.
Men vi ska faktiskt göra ett litet gym här, så vem vet, vi kanske slår det en pringar sen.
Jag har funderat på att köpa mjukisar här i oktober, så jag trycker nog in på hemsidan också.
Kan vi byta mjukisar med en skivstrång?
Vi klipper det.
Stort tack, ha det gött.
Ha det.
Nu ber jag om ursäkt till alla som lyssnar, för nu tänker jag prata om mjukisbyxor i tre minuter.
Men jag är en mjukbyxsekund, jag är en sån som köper mjukbyxor på hösten.
Och sen går jag liksom med dem i ett halvår.